you're listening to the dollop on the
all things comedy Network my name my
being nipple have her Oh double MIT man
[Music]
it's not okay face guy lover of the
a-team as a child Dave Anthony needs a
story from American history to his amigo
hey Gareth Reynolds who has no idea what
the topic is gonna be about that's the
best one you've done that's Julie that's
your best work cuz it was really insane
it seemed pretty on the nose like I
talked about things that are true you
bragged about having nipples in a face
well and they're like the a-team okay
number one there are people out there
without nipples and without faces so I'm
putting out there that those are the
things that I have also the a-team was
good all right well we can just start it
I guess and call the quote is jam-packed
Jim I'm the [ __ ] guy okay and this is
not gonna come particularly quad does
yeah
hard proficient now hit him with the
puppy you both present sick arguments
dad my friend
and that was you
the some of those parts in there yeah no
no I know it's name yeah you have you
have parts in the intro it's not just me
no I'm totally aware yeah but you're
also like in there like I'm just gonna
shout out some dates right now that
they're not related to history I'll be
on a tour for stand up this summer June
dates 6 through the 8th good night's
comedy club Raleigh North Carolina
Burlington Vermont Vermont comedy club
13th through the 15th 20th through the
22nd the comedy attic in Bloomington
Illinois comedy off Broadway Lexington
Kentucky 27th through the 29th you
totally flubbed that one all right
laughs Boston the 19th and 20th of July
August I'll be at the improv in Denver
the 9th through the 11th 17th I'll be at
the Abbey in Seattle why are you taking
a picture of me could you just be normal
for I just feel like you see the movie
Clifford with Martin Short and Charles
Grodin there's a great life Rachel urge
Alice Cronin looks at him and just like
can you be a normal boy Kent is it
possible and then comedy on State
Madison Wisconsin 22nd through the 24th
and that's on out that's on State Street
right please stop helping and some of
those do not have tickets up on the
website yet to buy just so people know
oh that's right also making lesson a
Saturday I will be at the Westside
Theatre doing stand-up comedy here in
Los Angeles and then May 7th I will be
at the dojo at the Sycamore tavern and I
think that'll be at 8 o'clock all right
I just put that up on the Instagram what
did you put up on the insert the picture
I took it's not bad just normal
existence
this is who we are we're out we're out
in front of public eye yeah yeah it's
just not a lot of people internally
paparazzi but we are brought to you by
zip recruiter
zip recruiter of course is a place where
you can find humans to do work let's
let's put it less crazily okay yeah for
them for the hiring used to be hard
multiple job sites stacks a resumes a
confusing review process but today
hiring can be easy and you only have to
go to one place to get it done zip
recruiter dot-com slash dollop there we
go
that's us we're the dollop and then we
are working with you got into the goof
gym a lot of either look a zip recruiter
with their powerful matching technology
they scan thousands of resumes to find
people with the right experience and
invites them to apply for your job now
what what job is that you were looking
for an employee for for a gear core yeah
we're fully staffing right now we're
staffing the warehouse your staff in the
warehouse yeah what so what kind of
experience we need a pallet commander
commander we need a commander the
pallets
we need forklift doctors were after
stacking agents we want floor dropping
lists truck yep and we're also we're
also looking for some door enthusiasts
oh those are all gonna be listed on zip
recruiter under the gear core yeah and
we're hiring lots yeah as applications
come in super cooter analyzes each one
and spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match so this sounds
like it's gonna be great for you it's
been great and right now our listeners
can try zip recruiter for free at this
exclusive web address zip recruiter
dot-com slash dollop let's zip recruiter
comm slash dollop do leop zipper
guru.com slash dollop zip recruiter the
smartest way to hire mmm-hmm so you know
if you're least seeking people ya who
need work which I am we already covered
this
we did yeah we talked a lot about it
right we also brought to you by Brooklyn
yes makers of sheets and elegant elegant
carefully crafted things you can have
sex on yes among many other options you
spend a third of your life in sheets
it's about time for a bedding upgrade
yeah why we we each have a pair of
Brooklyn and Comm sheets they're very
comfortable before leaving in yours yeah
than I do mine yeah you're there you
know you're on the back yard but I get
it right so I'll put Gareth in a sheet
and I'll throw him in the it's a I would
call it a ditch yeah no it's a it's an
under it's an underground bed yeah okay
yeah so that's where he but but when he
puts the the Brooklyn and sheets around
him he's like I I feel like you do that
and you have a good layer of soil there
you feel like an earthworm
yeah it's dinah yeah dynamic that's why
you call it earthworm it yeah yeah yeah
so you can do that with the sheets you
can also put them on a bed that's what
me and the wife - inside here you have a
pair that are black jet black right nope
your angle on this bit is not in a great
way
people love that I do not stop doing the
same thing over and over again and it
brings me joy knowing that there's
people out there getting mad about
something that shouldn't matter
mmm so we're both big fans of these
sheets winner of the online Betty guy
category from Good Housekeeping tons of
great reviews 35,000 five-star reviews
they're great they were founded in 2014
by a husband and wife Vicky and rich
Fulop Oh almost like dual op which is
the name of our podcast their mission
was to make five-star quality sheets
more affordable and easy to order and
darned if they didn't do it so we
recommend them Brooklyn sheets are the
best most comfortable sheets we've ever
slept on now it's time for your upgrade
Brooklyn and Comm is giving an exclusive
offer just for our listeners get 10% off
your first order and free shipping when
use promo code the dollop at Brooklyn
komm Brooklyn so confident in their
product that all their sheets comforters
and towels come with a lifetime warranty
the only way to get 10% off your first
order and free shipping is to use promo
code dollop the dollop at Brooklyn and
calm that's be our o KL iin Ian calm
promo code the dollop Brooklyn these
really are the best sheets ever and of
course we are brought to you by ritual
it's a vitamin a situation look
everybody wants to keep their body
healthy and already I'm lying because
that's not me right okay I don't turn
this into some kind of weird confession
I'm a slumlord and my body's it's not
good no but surely just taking this will
like am NOT a lady I mean I could take
it I'm sure what I think you should try
it yeah yeah that's true
so a lot of people try to kill sorry yes
drink green smoothie that's your like
your deals with a day we're still most
likely not getting all the essential
nutrients we need and to ritual the
obsessively researched vitamin for women
it is transparent right they can this is
a vitamin you know what's inside because
most vitamins you don't right there's
like I assume most of them hair in them
except for this one yeah we're very
testing with the pills would you say it
was I'll take it thank you so much
doctor I'm not a doctor I just work at
CVS um and of course you know a lot of
people care by the stuff especially when
me more for trying to get pregnant
you're like what do we what are you
putting in your body and you vitamins
you don't know but they tell you they
take tons of vitamins believe me I know
you were right there for all of it
Rachel essential for women is the
multivitamin reimagined from d3 to
omega-3 rituals essential for women
helps fill gaps in a woman's diet there
no nausea capsule design is gentle on an
empty stomach and there's a mint tab and
every bottle to keep things fresh so you
don't get that fishy aftertaste common
with most omega-3s which is not a fan of
especially the Burpee you don't like
fish burger
pretty not into purpose yeah I don't
need that I love a fish burp
I know you do better health doesn't
happen overnight and right now Richard
was off offering our listeners ten
percent off during your first three
months fill the gaps in your diet with
essential for women a small step that
helps support a healthy foundation in
your body the visit ritual dot-com /
dollop to start your ritual today that's
10% off during your first three months
at ritual calm / da noise de Lappe noise
tilapia sure you are I'm just gonna cut
this part out what do wanna do doll okay
yeah I wasn't sure what we're here for
yeah it's been pretty clear no okay
December 16th 1849 of our Lord Jesus
Christ yep Richard C flower dick flower
dick flower continued was born in Ohio
raised on a farm father was a reverend
okay he left home at 13 to make his own
way in the world sure it's just how you
did it yeah you're like look dad I
finally got the hairs on the the lower
parts I'm Haley
it really is has become normal to hear
that now on the show yeah and your
parents were like oh I get it you're 13
I was wondering when he was gonna get
off his ass and make some of us don't
you be working on a ship I'm - I
remember what I had to go to the airport
alone when I was like 13 terrifying I
was like I can't handle this yeah this I
died here yeah and you did and I died
there yeah yeah I'm still there dead
yeah that's the best part of our podcast
yeah so when he was 15 he he'd he'd
become a well known boy preacher in
Indiana Ohio so he's one of those young
preacher types the people like look his
boy and his magic talking
really crazy to you that totally he
entered Butler University studied
medicine but instead of getting a degree
there he got a totally [ __ ] medal of
the medical degree from a fraudulent
Ohio medical school which is just as
good yeah one thing you could do that I
mean aside from actually getting
education but you could just go to
someone and be like can I be a doctor
and they'd be like yeah how much money
do you have this much money can I be a
really good doctor you're the best thank
you so much brain surgeon oh my lord how
does one do it crack it like an egg or
do I just you know what I'm the doctor
what am I asking I'm the best brains but
he and I we had a guy that we gave it a
retuning he just goes through the eye
oh that's interesting yeah that's I
don't think I'm gonna do that you can
pop him out I'll write gonna go top in
top ins good see what happened I don't
really care I just want the money I
don't care either I just want to be able
to get out there and really start
getting into some bodies by any means
possible that's right your doctors in
two bodies great all right also go
through the chest to get to the brain
boy there's a lot of great options yes I
am excited to spread the word so I'm
just gonna grab this degree put it up on
the wall and all right I'll see you
later doctor Thank You Squire no I'm not
a squire so after he gets the medical
degree he goes back to the church and he
was put in charge of different parishes
from 1869
can I just sorry to jump in can I just
say that I already kind of like the
combination doctor young man of the
cloth and faux doctor Wow see a lot of
potential upside to Jesus in our way
maybe have you heard about my new show
preacher doctor
oh yes because ABC's doing doctor
preacher that's right which I heard is
right that's the one to see yeah and
then there's and then there's a spin-off
nighttime doctor preacher oh yeah good
night yeah preacher after dark dog yes
that's right so he then decided to study
law and he graduated from Northwestern
University with a law degree now if I if
I there was a lot there's a lot of
different versions of this guys
so I was trying to gone through them but
it seems like it took a year okay
okay yep so he kept preaching he grew
quite popular he was quote a very
convincing talker
sure but you need to be right yeah
you're bringing people around now if
you're throwing a lot of [ __ ] out
there you got to be convincing yeah yeah
it's like QVC for God yeah that's right
you do it was meant for me right
no pretty [ __ ] pointed comment you
are it's not there but then he was
accused of libel after he wrote a bunch
of letters to a former a parishioner so
I couldn't find out what was in the
letters they just said he was accused of
libel and actually so was he it went to
court and lost the case okay because
he's you know just clearly don't have
letter liable I was what this is when
you did letters I mean yeah that's now
it's different but yeah back then it was
either paper a letter so he's out lose
the case he's and now he's not in the
church heads to Philadelphia takes up
medicine okay though other doctors in
town were not fans of his methods well
because he didn't have any is that yeah
I think I think he was just kind of miss
his word totally manufactured and not
based on he was really I mean if anybody
was winging it he was winging like I'm
not to say let's adhere to what the laws
they found of medicine in the eighteen
hundreds the best because they're not
good we should go back to those we
should not miss matter of fact I'm
opening up a new hospital called 1803
1800s only medicine 1843 gonna open you
up put a little dirt in you go in the
back we're gonna have a horse kick in
the tummy all right now we're gonna put
beetles all over your face it's a lot of
bug eating so he still has a successful
practice despite that celebrities and
stuff come to him he's he's killing it
because Liberty I don't know I didn't
they didn't go into celebrities we got
their pikemen Pete yes he's one of them
but people know in in Philadelphia
because he's also a good talker right
he's if I can he knows how to talk yeah
convince people that's what I've always
found a bit better about a doc this is
the best start yes but then he goes to
Boston and he started working at the fs
Shaw tanning and leather company sure it
was a very prosperous business before he
got there and after it failed rather
quickly okay
pretty much everyone at the company and
involved blamed Richard for the failure
but isn't he content at not really being
a lawyer and not at all a doctor yeah I
don't know I don't know if he's listened
I would say that this is a gentleman who
is not content and is always looking for
a way to make more money okay
his next next skater for Peoria where
you go got involved in coal properties
people on coal situations in the ground
sure that and was this clean color this
was the dirty this is dirty okay
interesting you bring that up so that
ended up with a flurry of lawsuits aimed
at Richard and him running out of town
what were the lawsuits basically just
shenanigans oh he was going for
shenanigan next came this is interesting
so then he moves on so he gets involved
in Cola learns a little bit of coal and
then he goes someone starts the chem
comm company the chem calm yep Kem Kom
company he runs it he said the company
had invented a compound to make coal
burn more efficiently which would get
rid of the black smog in cities ah
clean coal like you said yeah the
compound burned out the grates and
boilers in which it was being used which
meant it wasn't really a thing and then
the company folded in all the investors
sued him
okay so it feels like a good amount of
misfires so far and maybe not finding an
occupation to land on is that safe I
mean look he's not he's trying to find
he's gone he's he's swinging big I mean
that's doing he's [ __ ] swinging big
everywhere he goes sure
the chem comm company seems like it was
[ __ ] okay from the beginning okay I
was trying to bring up the pictures for
you because any of the pictures yeah can
you just say oh wow okay yep so it looks
like every other guy in the 1800's yep
he looks a little squirrelly yeah as
they all did back then hair combed a
little bit too tight yeah little tiny
little tiny glasses I feel like those
are the only glasses they had back there
were not a lot of options for a lot of
things there's a little round e one yes
just what did you get a shirt I got one
shirt same shirt we all they have one
shirt Oh mom I got an answer a text what
for my wife it's about it's about dinner
next week look you got to be able to
multitask when you're doing a dollop you
know I mean no I don't like so next week
I'm gonna start exercising I have an
exercise bike in here I'm gonna exercise
here during the show yeah while I doll
up I'm gonna be on the bike I don't
think that's a good idea well get used
to it cuz I'm teaching a spin class here
in three weeks I'm gonna start teaching
spin class in here during the show
that's right
Wow you know maybe you should think
about getting in shape thank you and not
and not and not crushing the dreams of
people who are trying to get in shape
you're right yeah I was a monster back
there
I was a real chem Kong I didn't want to
say it Richard headed back to Boston
good he formed a couple of land
companies for developing you know land
projects sure they both went under okay
pretty quick he headed back back to
medical practice I was gonna say that
was really where he's on the [ __ ] yeah I
think he was the best at not being a
doctor he opened up the hotel flower
which was a sanatorium with a medium who
was part of the cure process Wow
progressive yeah yeah I mean he's uh I
think I think every doctor should have a
medium in their hotel office yeah well
welcome to the hast
I think I've sanitariums a little bit
different background I think people come
and stay for a while and it's not it's
place to check yourself into for health
right you know yeah it's not like a
hospital hospital right so it's kind of
Hotel it eventually became the plaza
that building well they saw it they saw
a different version yeah so you know you
go in and you're like hey my my leg
feels weird and he's like you talk to
this psychic that's right
talk to the psychic here she doesn't
think it's your actual leg what is she
your uncle killed your friend oh I know
we're gonna solve this right now the
Boston Globe quote he refused to be
bound by any system or code which is the
best like if you're looking for a doctor
I want someone that works outside the
box
who's a renegade someone who doesn't
believe in what the books are telling
him other doctors attacked his methods
he would have to go to hearings in the
legislature in Massachusetts to defend
himself he would he would lecture
frequently around Boston on health
subjects and during a couple claimed he
had found cures for cancer and
consumption okay so he's he's sounds
like he's killing it well literally
killing people probably I mean he's
literally as I said he has cancer he's
[ __ ] awesome well it's just that I do
feel like that hasn't stuck really yeah
because the whole didn't work or
whatever yeah maybe you shouldn't [ __ ]
on idea people well okay sorry how about
but trying to let someone have a dream
you do you give someone that opportunity
mmm but like once maybe twice on a check
to Texas he was arrested for charges
against him in Chicago for skipping out
on investors he was released on bail and
that arrested for his part in the Peoria
Cole fiasco uh-huh
a man claimed Richard had embezzled
three hundred thousand from him Peoria
Richard was then tried but not convicted
okay he heads for New York good the big
city yeah let's do this
there he opened the flower medical
company which sold a new liquid cure the
he called Sagwa okay get yourself some
sag wa sure what I fix that I owe its
sag was for the I well it's for all
kinds of things what like what what do
you have a question about sag was I will
fix that so you're gonna prescribe me
sag what to answer my question about
what sag was that's right
alright fixes every my babies to Harry
yeah it'll get a get rid of the hair I
have another baby who's not hairy enough
amazingly you that baby will get hair
I'm a man who would like womanly bosoms
they are now yours Sagwa helps you get
bosoms I want a leg to be where my arm
is sag wa oh I can do that in the
background
mmm sag woe is bottled and Sultan secure
for any ailment rheumatism arthritis
back pain stomach ulcers and most
importantly quote spiritual and physical
sag okay so sag WA is what just some do
you have this water feel satsang water
do you feel saggy
does a dr soul sag do ya do you have
social security of physical sag what are
you feeling sag no then you don't need
it yeah although what it would help
bring back that spark in your eye is a
lecture actually had no medical value no
medicinal value at all sure but i did
have quite a bit of alcohol in it so oh
that's good not a lot of people were
complaining it yes that is smart
i can't my things better my soul has
never felt better every second it does
really well he opens up an office on 34
feet literally it just does well cuz
it's booze yeah but also a cure stuff
yeah booze cures stuff in the moment a
famous guy i didn't put this in there
but some famous guy either owner
Tiffany's or board member Tiffany's said
he came back from Europe and he had some
affliction and he tried sag what it
fixed him so there were people that were
like yeah I mean the thing about these
kind of things is you could have
something that is
temporary malady right and then you
drink the [ __ ] here like I'm cured I
better yeah just you know it is the
advantage of knowing nothing yeah so he
he's this is the good years he's living
good right he's making a good year yeah
he's living good he's making money off
of this
office on 34th Street gets married but
word that his cure was [ __ ] got out
over time and he was starting to be
attacked by the press as we're kind of
all snake met a snake oil salesman
they're now being called quacks in a
herd of times and on top of that laws
are starting to be proposed to regulate
medicines okay so that's [ __ ] no but
the writing is on the wall interesting
fact they had less measles back then oh
my god are there measles now there can't
be measles because we can apply
vaccination no no no no we eradicated we
don't know dude no no are you talking
about their kids measles dude measles is
back it's awesome it can't because we
all it's like Murphy Brown thanks man
we all got vaccinated no some of us are
like let's not and then we'll mingle
around the mega regular population and
then we'll give them all measles oh my
god it's so weird cuz my my doctor does
not have a medical degree but she was a
penthouse centerfold so I usually just
listen to what she says and she told me
to did not give accident sounds like
you're at a flower Hospital bingo and
we're back actually lost a friend
because of Jenny McCarthy because I said
she's a piece of [ __ ] and he's like
she's a friend of mine okay
she's a piece of [ __ ] don't go in her
pool
yeah so since the writing's on the wall
right the the the snake oil business is
gonna be [ __ ] pretty soon sure the
government's coming so for decades
Richard had heard rumors of the mineral
deposits on the San Carlos Apache
reservation in Arizona the mineral
deposits okay you know sure the minerals
and now the area was being opened up to
mining the Graham County Garden oh boy
he's gonna find some real [ __ ]
you okay yeah yeah you got a cold
just pill you got allergies you got a I
mean it is a nightmare to be about to
blow your nose and I'm gonna record it
show me like can we listen there it is
you got to do this slow blow yeah
there's just Lourdes almost wurr story
like nobody'll know if I just go it's
always bad when a guy takes like four
Kleenexes out of it yeah yeah you're
either about to get a cold or jerked off
so these rumors about this Apache
reservation that it's full of minerals
the Graham County Guardian paper had
written quote this is undoubtedly one of
the richest pieces of mineral bearing
earth in the southwest in 1877 the
handbook to Arizona was published by
Richard Hinton Arizona Territory papers
used journalists to publish their
political agendas and writers were
pressured to come up with exciting
stories that were not at all accurate
well how imagine yeah the writers
published books and pamphlets full of
elaborate nonsense outies people are
reading about this they can't get enough
of the stories so there's mineral thing
is just kind of set up by BS journalism
just they're saying serving the state's
business yeah and they want people to
move out there I know fake doctor flower
is like huh bs minerals hey I can get
I've been bullshitting everybody about
everything I sold whiskey as an upper so
he yeah I mean they want people to move
out because more people out there means
more money they want to get their hands
on the Apache land and they keep telling
people the the fighting with the Apaches
is waning like it's just all [ __ ]
stories to get people to move out oh
that's an interesting detail yeah so the
more they heard about the wedding threat
of Apaches the more they wanted to head
out and strike it rich
hitting's handbook said it was a healthy
climate for what we're called longers oh
the loggers you mean the people with
Sep tional the awesome lungs ya know
they're the people with tuberculosis oh
yeah come on out of your lung or what
the dry desert air is perfect for you
and you hear that you're like boy I
should go where all those people that
have TB and coffee wobble longer sorry
miss McCarthy whites pushed Congress to
remove the mining areas from within the
boundaries of the Apache reservation
ranchers and prospectors illegally
invaded the reservation and started
staking claims okay this here's my land
now I'm staking a claim right we
actually own this right not anymore I
put up my four before twigs I'm here
announced man yeah I'm a [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] who's got all this stuff cuz I
said so and a copper was found and there
was enough coal for the new railroad and
people said the mines could provide work
for the Apaches right so they found coal
they're like we can put the Apaches to
work in the coal mines and certainly any
Apache would want to go deep in the
tunnels you dig the [ __ ] out of the
ground and exchange for cash right that
is to them natural that's exactly how
they were doing it most Native Americans
dug the deepest of mines do we ever
wonder why the Native Americans are
upset with us showing up it's sometimes
it's I don't I don't see the downside it
feels like we came here with barrels and
barrels of delicious selfish capitalism
yeah I mean we just were like [ __ ] share
sharing the experience I don't think
there's anything better and then whoever
thought up money is the best yeah
because it's worked out great yeah for
government it meant they would not have
to feed the Apaches if the Apaches were
working in coal mines so it's a win-win
for everybody I don't understand well so
they're there right now they're on a
reservation they're hit land that they
can't take care of themselves anymore so
they have to feed them right and now
here's a solution put them underground
in
get them black long and they can make a
little bit scratch its so we're like I
said a romantic story it's a win-win
yeah everybody wins because in the end
of this they can buy a sweet car
whatever yeah yeah for sure
so in 1898 Congress restored the San
Carlos mineral strip to the public
domain so they took this one strip that
is in the reservation that is full of
minerals and they they go oh that's not
that's not part of the reservation now
remember how it was it's not right so
this is just gerrymandering oh yeah oh
we're gonna take the thing that we gave
you you messed up the line it's here now
the Graham County Guardian cheered
Congress for their wonderful decision
the paper wrote that a government
inspection had found that the land was
quote rich in gold silver copper and
coal all of the things the important
things this sounded like a great
opportunity to Richard flower
unfortunately richer fortunately Richard
had never been Arizona and knew
absolutely nothing about mining yeah but
that why would why would you feel like
he would stop why would that be like a
problem for no I mean he did doctor
stuff yeah he had no idea what doctors
do no this is the guy who invented Sagwa
in the 10th Kim Kim Kim and Kim cam cam
so he so the word mazuma means money in
yiddish and he his lawyer came up with
the spanish uma mineral company so they
like took a look they wanted to sound
like zoom a little bit and then it
should be terrible but complicate
spanish spent a zoom I don't know where
that came from
Ben Zuma spent money spent is Uma yeah
it's all great but yeah it's a bad
indicator yeah so the the spasm of
mineral company is born one of those
ones where he's probably saying it to
people like hey yeah zoom right yeah no
you wouldn't
right give up money right cuz I said
span assume
Juanes been assumed yeah we're gonna
[ __ ] do this
mmm we're gonna do this yeah I mean you
know I'm oh you know you're just the guy
telling me a story no I'm a goat herder
so that's my job we're New York City
yeah the move hasn't gone great goats
aren't happy
so his medical office was quickly
converted to the spen Asuma headquarters
well I mean yeah it's not like he's
gonna miss it
yeah he could pretty still practice
medicine just as well the office door
now had the word gold on the front
that's important oh that's important he
printed up gold bordered stock
certificates in ten dollar denominations
it should be about a hundred bucks today
so not a crazy amount of money it's not
he's not just going for rich people he's
like I can get you know the middle class
and well there's a really big not a sell
these gold $10 a share okay and then you
owe $10 a share in this business I'm a
mining riot which is as we all know
going to go great of course it is yeah I
starts making trips out to the Arizona
Territory you're off Mike you're off
Mike I look at that there's one I wanted
to buy that it's so we I pulled up a
certificate was it was it called a stock
stock certificate and it's um I wanted
to buy this a hundred and one thousand
five hundred dollars so that you're
coming to me now [ __ ] on but yeah but
I'm saying we should get in on this
but David just doesn't I don't know I
mean this is all along you think now I
trust you think it's the time to invest
and spend Zuma I just want the stock
certificate to put on my wall do you
think that we're gonna make some money
on a spend as Emma yeah so he starts
making trip stairs on a territory
several over the next few months first
time there he made his way to the town
of Geronimo a bustling a bustling town
was
brothels blacksmiths and two Chinese
restaurants Wow okay I know isn't that
interesting but then you think about it
and you think of course Chinese are
coming yeah for work yeah and building
the railroads and whatnot so of course
there's Chinese restaurants in the West
every single town it's delicious yes so
Richard hired two men alkali Tom and
Bill Duncan alkaloid Tom alkali alkali
Tom it's just a classic western name
sure
seventy percent of men in the West were
named alcohol sure okay
they set out for the Black Rock region
Black Rock was not on the reservation or
within the mineral strip boundary but
Richard did not care okay so he's now
invading to get his minerals he's
heading to a place but I think he does
can I tell you my fear yeah god it's
gonna be dangerous why I don't think
he's thinking no it'll be fine okay so
he stabbed he sized up Tom alkaloid Tom
as a snaky dude who is skilled in the
ways of not legal stuff yeah which was
true his regular job was being a cattle
wrestler keep going man no Duncan was a
tough cowboy type who had robbed a
stagecoach or two at his time and now
was the hotel clerk and a higher
available as a hired hand okay so a
couple of good couple of rows that are
right guy yeah as they rode up to
Blackrock Duncan told Richard that the
imposing rock was called Montezuma by
the Apaches who guarded and he and
Montezuma guarded over the area so the
rock so so that's the rocks the rock is
a like a so and what you're saying is
that Guardian rock what you're saying
okay and just the way you snuck that in
is important so essentially he and two
[ __ ] are now going to what could be
called God Rock governor to take it
apart for their business they're gonna
fire you
partners well they're going to be there
probably collecting on land that has not
been established as something they can
legally be going to well I mean I think
they can legally because it's not on the
reservation and it's not okay
parent middle strip so really you can
just steak lamb but Montezuma probably
important great pool sure Richard took
rock samples and shipped them back to
New York he started buying any claim
around Blackrock he could get his hands
on okay
now bill Duncan was like this and
everyone's tried this place there's
nothing here but Richard hires surveyors
laborers carpenters and miners to work
his claims okay he spread more money
around to forge relationships with other
mine owners nearby okay then he hired a
photographer to document the progress at
the span Asuma mining company camp I
feel like he's overspending workers laid
out a town site which was called span
Asuma just get over it everyone got to
work creating what was a completely were
completely fake mines and I can a camp a
town okay
Richard hoped a Richard hope Richard
hopped a train back to New York or he
put together a gold bordered prospectus
full of photos and amazing description
promising investors instant riches
there's a fire fest vibe except no one's
blowing anybody for for water or water
but although people could be blowing
each other for a while but it's just
also propped up on all the the things
that seem important visually no it's but
underneath it feels like there's really
no subs oh there's no it's just [ __ ]
garbage okay
a giant heap of garbage okay how great
would it be a fire fest in another one
talking about it at one point I just
keep
for that to happen so the prospectus is
sent out across the east and a little
bit in the Midwest quote running through
the center of this property is a vein of
or 1/2 mile in width and 2 miles in
length okay it's a pretty big main
that's in a bigger vein yeah every foot
of it rich in gold copper and silver it
is said this is the richest and largest
continuous vein of ore quote rich from
the surface rock into the bowels of the
earth ever discovered in the world so
this is now just another selling
component of more sort of investment yep
right okay yeah the saying it's this is
the biggest discovery of all or is great
that's the best he's he spent another
tale based on Duncan's story of
Montezuma okay he sped his bed he said
span Asuma had been an actual guy this
is just miles ago and now spent is like
he's in love with his like it's in love
with this idea that nobody else is in
love with her name sounds like now it's
been assumed as a guy I know spin assume
is going to mana Sumer what do you mean
spending zoom is going to Mars over
there Montezuma is where spent to Zuma
is going to Ben Asuma Montezuma is the
name of the rock that the that's what
the Apaches couldn't even know if that's
true like Duncan just could've just been
talking [ __ ] so here's the story spend
zoom is actual guy he is the son of
legendary Aztec chieftain Montezuma
Jesus sparrows oma had been the first
person just to discover the gold at
Blackrock but he's not interested in it
he doesn't care it's not his thing okay
so it just sat there for years just
[ __ ] sitting then this giant vein of
ore
until a professor in mining expert named
T a hal chu ha Hal Chu yep from long
horn Montana spoke to an old Mexican man
now the professor's not a real person
and longer Montana doesn't exist anyway
he talks the Lord would have it he talks
to this old Mexican guy now the old
Mexican guy happens to be on his
deathbed okay so he's just spinning out
true truths yeah no for sure deepest
secrets know towards the end is worth
the logic really kind so for whatever
reason the professor's next to has been
and the old Mexican guy tells hat so he
just this is this guy no one before he
just goes over there we don't know okay
we don't know we didn't get that number
into it okay so the old Mexican guys
tell tells how to about the or and the
Mexicans man said the or was under a
rock formation that looked like span
asuma's profile which is exactly what
that looks like
lucky can see the mouth and the eye and
then he's got a really fucked-up nose
but it's there I mean it's been in some
fights the nose has been in some fights
but that's that's the face of a our dear
spinosum oh he said it was named Black
Rock Richard buys full-page ads and
newspapers with the story of spin is Uma
and the rich vein of ore he hires
pitchman to go around promoting as the
Meyer fest
this is I think they are all fire fest
anything yet but this thing has happened
so many times in the history of the
world it's just another one yeah but
it's just it like how shiny you make
this [ __ ] the [ __ ] is just like if
you spent some time not shining the
[ __ ] maybe there wouldn't be so much
[ __ ] to shine it's I mean it's a
good point
so these pitchman would go to small
towns they tell the story they use
lanterns to show slides along with their
sales pitch from the photos that the
photographer's taking of the town they
share the pictures were not of Richards
mines they were of other but that's
neither here no but the point is we know
where these mines are that's right
they're not ours
yeah and once ours gets going it'll be
similar to this probably they're like
these are this is our mind and it's
other people's minds it's weird when you
lie about something like when it's not
your mind yeah let's say it's mine yeah
it's so fun I don't like doing this
podcast with you I'm happy here yeah
yeah okay one called himself one of the
pitchman calls himself HB Clifford and
said he was the Commissioner of Arizona
ah we all know that guy has direct
contact with Phoenix Batman I made up a
ridiculous name for my position I'm
constable of Tucson I'm the mayor of
Arizona quote if you purchase mining
stocks by those of big companies and
then he just slides the big companies of
which spent as Emma was always one
uh-huh okay after he lists her whisper
to people if they came to his hotel he'd
give him a hot tip oh and the people
would come out the way someone tells you
to come to their hotel for a hot tip
I've done that it's not great so it
turns out the hot tip is Spanish uma I'm
not in company yeah it works
people buy stock in under a year people
have purchased over three million
dollars worth of stock oh my god well
who needs a mine you've made your money
it's like 30 million today it's you've
made your money yeah the people from all
over the town of traval in New York put
their money together and bought 60,000
where the stock
the spinosum a mining company stock rose
to $15 a share from 10 and then 12 now
15 the dividend brought even more
investors in the Graham County Guardian
got it on the action printing stories
about the mining company they were
written by people who were actually at
the mine not the papers writers right
okay actual people at the musher it
turns out they were all employees of
Richard of the mining company oh okay
so they just neglected to tell the paper
that part okay so one wrote 35 men were
working day and night shifts at the mine
tons of wood and equipment was in route
to build the mine it was a big operation
according to the article mine owners
were planning on building an electrical
plant a mess hall and other structures
including a reading room for the miners
ah yes which as we know about mine
owners every mine on it has a reading
room well and they're also incapable of
reading outside of a designated space
that's right because otherwise you know
yeah where are you gonna read yeah it's
hard to find a place to read a book
here's a picture of mine is that the
real mine oh yeah this is actually this
is the actual mine so there's
photographs taken by the photographer
doing something yeah they're doing
something sound like your hearts in it
so the reading room was obviously a
probably I assume a big success sure
yeah one long article a guy wrote about
the building of a dry goods store two
saloons and a quote first-class market
hmm a goal market yeah the yeah I mean
here's the thing about mine ours they
always had like a Gelson's and and then
a reading room all right guys get your
acai bowls
what was the ACI a balls people love
those acai acai yeah that's what oh the
sorry Barry yeah
yeah I shall call it Chi okay sorry
Barry
yeah they basically open up a zoo bars
and a nice okay so looks the mine was
gearing up to crank out 500 tons a day
so oh there's also great times happening
quote a grand ball was given at this
place last Thursday evening in the new
mill house about a hundred to feel less
like a mine sounds like Google now about
150 people participated and enjoyed
themselves immensely
it was the grandest social event in the
history of the camp like if you invested
in this wouldn't you be like get to work
get to work also why don't we you should
not be going to a reading room herballs
yeah and why are why why are there 150
people and whatever the whole thing's
you know you're gonna love it we're
gonna be playing horseshoes and bocce
ball we have a barbecue every day the
corn corn all cornhole corn oh we're
playing together cornhole we can
absolutely get a corn home we can do
whatever we want I would like to work at
the mine the mine is great we have four
pieces of wood set up oh and one of
those little love wood trolleys my mom
was my mom when I scratch here's the
great thing about our mind - yeah we
don't mind we just part oh yeah that's
the kind of mine I've been looking for
ya know where there's just parties in a
reading room yeah there's a reading room
this is why I've always been like I want
to be a miner by the way some people
have been jerking off in the reading
room and not reading oh that's just a
side effect of detonating a space for
something that could be done anywhere
actually the exact kind of reading room
I'm looking for that's awesome because I
didn't want to straight up say it but
we've changed the reading room now it's
just the jacks pot see I want to make
movies which aren't I think I've had the
same dream I've wanted my idea my movies
that I stand in front of people and I
masturbate I'll tell you what as a guy
who also shares the love of future
cinema right which again is not a thing
yet so it's hard to fathom us having
this conversation I love the idea but I
want to stand in front of people on
masturbate and say wait you think about
it
was on a screen ya know it's almost like
you could be a comedian yeah yeah yeah
anyway yeah anyway pipe dreams
so Richard put together a board of
directors made up of some buddies and
fake people
sure fake people are great for the board
the fake board went on a not real trip
to spend Zuma to inspect the mining
operation oh good because you want to be
sure that it's everything's up to you no
standards well they came back with a
fantastic report Oh from the trip they
didn't tell ya okay great
quote a few months ago this camp was the
center of the vastness of the wild
uninhabitable country today it is a city
of white tents good if there was ever a
spot on earth especially for a great
mining camp it is this span asuma valley
we found this great mining property
richer greater and more valuable than
ever claimed by the company in their
prospectus you can dig anywhere for two
or three feet and expose a rich body of
or so so the same money to be coming
back to people pretty I mean you
literally walk around and just wherever
you dig oh do me a favor find a place
where there's not or thank you we just
want to make a well yeah Lord
the board then said the mines were worth
at least $24 a ton Oh
so that's like double in the price and
that would soon rise to 150 per ton well
how's the operation was really going boy
so the [ __ ] is really low [ __ ]
is crazy really it's a valuable time to
be in the [ __ ] yeah apparently this
was still not enough for Richard do you
publicly publicize it further Richard
arranged to have a select group of
potential investors visit the mine
okay these are all prominent men and if
the trip worked out they would he would
issue another ten million or the stock
god
so they took several trains to Arizona
there is a mine though
there's the I mean he has gone about
building out his claim so they have dug
holes in the ground
that's not a yes there's holes in the
ground okay I mean they're deep holes
but they're not yeah but it's not mine
is an extensive but everything is
[ __ ] yeah okay
they booked several trains to Arizona
then they take carriages for the last
leg Richard promised a break on the fare
$80 a trip that's nice that's great when
they arrived in drama apaches Teamsters
and prospectors all came out to greet
the Easterners excuse me you said we'd
be having lobster tails for lunch these
are just baloney sandwiches what is this
[ __ ] is that ja Rule yes - waiting fancy
coaches then took them from the town to
Black Rock okay as they're riding
Richard Sir Richard's up front with the
driver sure and he stands up and yells
hold up and then he shot toward a rock
pile near the road but everyone was very
confused and alarmed and then there was
nothing there
turns out Richard had set up two
henchmen to pretend to try to rob the
carriage but the guys weren't there
Oh God and he had to tell the investors
that he had seen a coyote and that's
what he had shot at I don't know why he
yelled hold up well cuz coyotes respect
commands oh my god so wait he'd hired
two guys to stage a robbery big robbery
and before they because the guys didn't
show up he was uber sorry
yeah and those guys weren't there so
that he was like there was a coyote
that's let's keep going yeah and also
don't depend on [ __ ] actors well one
of those guys was alkaloid Tom and it
turns out Bill Duncan had heard about
the plan and come and told them to not
do it and talk to me - coming back to
town because he thought the investors
would see right through it
yeah and he was like what would happen
when they did what are you gonna kill
them like I said all play out how was it
greasing the wheels none of it was part
of it to make him be like oh wow he's a
guy we could trust yeah and also like
the how exciting it is out here and also
oh he saved us from these guys right
ology okay [ __ ] really just runs like
a haunted house almost yeah yeah this is
like an early Disneyland right okay when
they got to the mind they were greeted
by explosion so as they're pulling up
they just hear boom boom because they're
sorry boys things are really active
around here well they're setting off
dynamite you know in the mines Zak yeah
because they're going for all the gold
oh well listen they got a dig real deep
to find this [ __ ] men are all moving
about it's all aflutter we're not actors
either they're all working for yard
watermelon watermelon watermelon
watermelon they're bringing up or so
guys are coming up with all this amazing
looking or from the mine and the
investors watch as a big load of ores
hauled off and a wagon
sorry you guys are catching us on a
light day normally there's a lot of or
hey I heard those henchmen stopped you
two others that's been dude that's the
most you know inch no those guys try to
take a year
oh the messes were fed then they went on
a tour of the mining complex I like they
even took a picture oh it's really clear
it's a bunch of the workers and then the
investor you know when I'm not I'm not
trying to crap on the technology of this
era this early photograph super early
yeah so I guess I mean for just people
with this one picture become a paper and
people like it's magic yeah this to them
is [ __ ] bananas that they can see
what happened somewhere else at another
time like this is truly [ __ ] crazy
yeah and now I look at it now and yeah
now it's not it's not a very good
picture no this would be really bad if
it was on Instagram yeah so they go into
mine shafts Richard pointed out the new
machinery that was like leg out not
installed yet he's like we're about to
install the machinery they were told to
take samples with the or with them
because it's so [ __ ] awesome
miles of it is everywhere get it out of
here
the or had actually been
brought from other mines and then
sprayed okay so this is a or sprinkled
with gold dust to make it look better so
this is a I mean this actually had a
name for it lying that's it's called
salting so you take actual real good or
from another mine you bring it to your
mind and then you put gold on it
whatever to make it look even better so
they see this pile of awesome [ __ ] that
they say just came out of your mind but
it didn't you know I just I I worry what
happens to this madoff it's fine they at
one point they take them down into a
mind because they've found like a vein
of mica which is oh yeah it's fool's
gold right and so this and they show
them and they're like it's a little ways
away they're like look gold in the guy
look fool's gold
yeah and these guys are all from New
York they they don't [ __ ] [ __ ] about
and they're like oh my god go go they're
over the [ __ ] don't let the coyote
get it or do uh-huh
so it was something everyone was very
excited and they all believed they were
about to become super wealthy like it
just [ __ ] hit it when they got back
to Geronimo Richard sent off telegrams
to newspapers and people he knew in New
York describing the awesome trip quote
everyone could buy span asuma stocks
with confidence and knowing and had been
investigated by prominent persons and
found to be even richer than represent
he also sent telegrams to his contacts
were in on the scam saying they would
have no trouble selling the additional
ten million or the stock right two years
before Arizona Territory officials had
become concerned that all the fig mines
popping up everywhere we're destroying
confidence in the mining business what
an irrational fear yeah someone
suggested that an agency should be
created to keep an eye on the industry
Oh regulation regulations we want
freedom yeah Oh legislature
the legislature approved it and then a
new paper and Phoenix Phoenix called the
Arizona Republic I just saw a couple
years before started the mining beat
okay
and now that's got to be good news for
Richard a reporter named George Smalley
was assigned to be the miner reporter
Lance so he's he's the mind beet guy
okay he's got the [ __ ] job
[Music]
photographs are so bad it's amazing but
they would be like oh my god Wow
so so he's the mine reporter he would
ride across just miles of empty land to
get to mines write up a story about what
was coming out of the ground how the
mine was operating the mine beat like a
crime be so was it sort of is his job
like he is he trying to be investigative
or is he just kind of go in there and
just reporting on what he sees the
marianas reporter okay he is very much
is he like a man who was like I will
write what I see okay we'll be honest in
Truckee right so in early 1899 just a
week after the happy investors had
headed back to New York
Smalley was headed over to a mine when
he ran into Bill Duncan okay and now
Bill Duncan for some reason was now a
disgruntled spinosum employee so
something had happened and he was like
[ __ ] this place okay
he told Smalley all about Richard's fake
mine and said he'd take him there okay
when they arrived there was none of the
activity that big going on when the
investors were there quite the
superintendent was lounging in a hammock
beneath the sycamore tree no sorry I
just got tired four more I've got so
much why the Golding old digs uh I've
been gone at night now and then during
the day I have
yeah it's just classic mine there's so
much that we don't need to work anymore
we took all that we could take out and
we need more but it's growing it's
growing back that's how it works
we need more hitting things yes
sharpened hammer pricings certain hammer
pointy thing that's a part of the that's
Oh after and then the bags to put the
ubiquitous minerals in years or we have
been truly blessed up here at Montezuma
alright now if you've got your head I
love mining so they were told the
property was not open for strangers to
inspect no no just people who are gonna
buy it but Duncan found a way for them
to sneak onto the property because he
knew [ __ ] everything about the place
sure they explored mine shafts and
tunnels which were all way too short
okay
Smalley looked at the buildings and
machinery and realized this setup was
ridiculous the buildings could never
hold the machinery that was there like
one was just one of the buildings he
went it was just like two-by-fours laid
on the ground like I need actual like
something to write one of them just said
the sign that just said this is an
active mind machine yer was much too
small for what legitimate mines would
use to crush our so it's just all at any
point are you starting to think that his
that this is not a good mind wow it
feels like a great mind I mean I was
still invest yes I'm just making sure
they saw the saltador so he's been in
them he's been in down in mines he sees
this pile of awesome Morrie's all
[ __ ]
Duncan told him which two mines the ore
was from but Smalley said I'll take it
from here I'm a reporter and I'll find
out where it came from myself
but I thought we was kind of partners no
we're not partners but I'm talking to a
reporter you're reporters you brought me
here we're reporters did your job I did
our job now I walk away from you I can't
end this I do my job I have issues with
goodbye
I know take me with you I'll be your
sidekick
I won't even bother you much I just need
a goddamn friend please come on
all right I'm gonna walk away you'll
regret this here I go I don't regret it
at all it feels great I'm betting that
Duncan and Richards falling out happened
when Duncan pulled the two henchmen away
from the yeah that's what I was yeah so
small he goes and investigates he spent
days questioning local supervisors of
mines and slowly discovered the full
operation one mine owner said Richard
had bought or from him to be shipped
back to New York as spent as Ouma or
that he was displaying currently in his
office Wow
there's nothing at spinosum oh just one
two-foot vein of sulphide quote no
copper no gold no silver just let when
small his investigation was going on
Richard was happily working his scam
back in New York he put out more fake or
testing reports it's so funny you can
find them oh wow the investors who had
visited were talking it up so all now
it's just like all these actual rich
prominent guys are out telling them I'm
out funny awesome it is together they
issued an affidavit so all the [ __ ]
rich guys who came together put out an
affidavit that said how awesome the
mining company was quote most of us
considered this prospectus a fairy tale
but candidly confess that it is not only
true but our own eyes have seen much
more than has been claimed and we
sincerely believe the property to be the
most valuable of its kind in the country
okay there we go Richard used the
affidavit to further promote the or
testing reports confirm
what the investors said it was now
estimated the mine could produce between
2500 and 10,000 per day Wow then on May
it's a lot considering it's empty
yep I mean consider there's nothing
there yeah really big numbers this is
very Enron oh yeah then on May 17 1899
smileys investigation story was
published in The Arizona Republic the
headline was quote a tenderfoot trap
okay he lays it all out okay
the fake are that many of the tents in
the supposed camp were empty and that
fake miners were paid $3 a day okay one
miner said quote this is the laziest
camp I ever struck yeah it's a great job
for them we have a good time during our
shift and very little work is done it's
a good it's a good time he said when the
investors were there they had been told
to act excited about the or they were
bringing out of the mine they also took
the investors into a mine and pointed
out the mica and said it was gold the
investors knew so little about mining
they believed everything yeah which is
why you want to definitely get an
affidavit involved 100% yeah Smalley
wrote that Richard and the mining
company were quote committing a crime
against Arizona which its people should
punish they are injuring the mining
interests of the entire territory which
I don't give a [ __ ] good [ __ ] mining
yeah I mean that's my honest response
[ __ ] mining yeah but this is before they
knew that yeah now they still know they
still know I'm [ __ ] anyone so [ __ ]
does it take my sweet mother earth my
little baby
I listen okay
when news made it back to New York the
value of the stock quickly fell to zero
huh that's way lower yeah it's a lot
lower do you have to make new
certificates I guess you yeah yeah
valueless nothing not they Richard tried
to save this window he hired an Arizona
lawyer to offer Smalley a $5,000 bribe
to retract his 17 page detailed article
and to write other stories explaining
how he was wrong he made millions of
dollars and he's offering him five
grant okay thank you so what a cheap
[ __ ] yeah like all of the money
that he put into this thing and then
he's just gonna offer five I grant you
offer this guy a million dollars I mean
that is your the future of your [ __ ]
mine is on the line
act like you give a [ __ ] and then he
wants him to write other [ __ ] more
stories I want it to be a series for
some reason smiley turned the offer down
what yeah the lawyer threatened to sue
the paper for $100,000 for libel then
mm-hmm he said the paper had quote
unsubstantiated reporting caused his
client unbearable stress and
considerable loss of income the paper
owners did not back down and the lawyer
eventually did you know the territorial
governor of Arizona then issued an
official proclamation warning Easterners
against ever investing in the s-pen ism
of mining company this is probably all
bad facts company has peaked at this
gentlemen we have to let you go yeah who
me I'm the only one over yeah it was
such a vast operation too like he really
if he focused on mining maybe he would
have gotten something but here's what he
did he did everything but keep the guys
who knew about it on his good side bill
Duncan mm-hmm right like the guy you
don't [ __ ] with yeah the guy who knows
everything and that's the guy effect
with because otherwise this is [ __ ]
rolling still you I mean look yeah you
got it you've got to bribe the people
properly so the publisher of the Graham
County Guardian did not look good now he
was forced to admit that the mining camp
was deserted and stocks he had been
advertising in the paper were worthless
okay
the local community was rocked
businesses had Commons set up ready for
the coming flood of riches so basically
a town had set up right waiting to deal
with all the or gold or copper and
silver I mean they were its saloons and
like everyone made it everyone was ready
yeah
they ordered products they waited but
once the truth is disposed everyone went
out of business it was over but Richard
yes
that's my man not one to give up it
would go fight baby less than a month
later he was back at it with another
fake mining operation in the penally no
mountains he called it
Lone Pine mining company there we go
so he's doing the exact same [ __ ]
thing
word got to Smalley pretty fast he went
out investigated he found the exact same
thing as he looked around a guy who was
with him yelled duck quote then followed
a dull thud of lead against the rocks
Smalley had been shot at Jesus they saw
two men with rifles aways away and some
trees after waiting a while and
realizing the men weren't going to shoot
again they approached the men both of
whom were standing there with rifles and
smile he accused them of shooting at him
one said they were just hunting rabbits
and that he should get off the claim
just a couple Elmer Fudd's oh we was
hunting rabbits also you need to leave
here feel like you shot at me Oh rabbits
yeah but you boys look like a rabbit
from from well boys blew up talk rabbits
rabbits around here by five foot eight
and they were closed
well maybe part of problem is we don't
know what a rabbit he is never seen no
rabbit
anyway we got our hands full or you get
out of here just so much all up here
that's my left and he wrote up another
story Richard I give you three pencils
to stop doing this Richard's done in
Arizona
he's just [ __ ] at this point but not
back east there we go
he continued to con and swindle and
became known by the name small he had
given him in the story the prints of
swindlers okay
he read up an 18 I read the whole thing
you read up an 18 page story on there's
a 18 which he put it together in 18 he
loved and faced man faced man you never
watched a team face
I've seen the a-team I've seen the
a-team yeah sure yeah yeah I mean don't
talk it's mr. T's world that were all
everyone else is just the sign character
that's just that's just a really [ __ ]
thing to say about face what else yeah
so he's now going by two different
aliases Oxford and Montgomery one man he
conned into buying stock in Spanish uma
was his friend Theatre Hegeman okay
Hagman invested three hundred thousand
Theodore died in 1902 and then Richard
went to his widow and confessed
convinced her to invest more money in a
different company oh dear
Richard and the widow's seemed pretty
close and hagman's heirs then brought a
suit against the widow and people began
to wonder if Richard had been part of
hagman's death
Osho Hagerman was dug up I thought he
might be poisoned in 1903 was Richard
like I don't know how to dig to get
anything oh you went to any of that I
don't know here's a spoon I got nothing
I am out of ideas just get a bunch of
machines around it and don't plug them
into anything
in 1903 Richard was indicted in New York
for calling a woman out of 50,000 in
another mining scam in a different state
like Colorado and he's doing into other
places a different woman from Brooklyn
paid his bail of 20,000 and then he
immediately skipped out on the bail and
headed for Philadelphia and she ended up
having to lose the 20 grand there in
Philadelphia he came more cons one of
which was that he figured out a secret
process to make real diamonds he what
why are you doubting man figured how to
make diamonds sure I mean it sounds
awesome yeah it sounds like the best
thing ever for sure yeah yeah I mean he
just figured it out
just feels like it's not no man you've
not heard of it recently so
here's some diamonds so you see them mmm
those are probably just regular diamonds
named in the backroom with what out of
the diamond machine what does it look
like can I say yeah pitcher can I see it
yeah so if you look at it your eyes can
die how did you get in there to look at
it
I wear special glasses and I just wear
those glasses are just going for me can
I I'm surely there's a way for me to get
a pair of those fitted for me I want to
invest a lot of money in this I just
need a pair of these I am dying in a
train accident well surely there's
another guy who could maybe try to make
another pair didn't leave the formula
well I mean I'm sure I could just can we
just take the lenses out of yours and
put them in like some some know that
they're made specifically for my eyes
it's just super convenient on someone
else's eyes be like where it smells what
happens if I look at it without those
your whole brain explodes oh but you're
a brain doctor so you'll be fine to fix
why I can't put together an exploded
brain I would need my medium for that
but he's in Boston so he even gave us
samples of the diamonds to potential
investors who would take them to experts
who pronounced them quote impossible to
be distinguished from the genuine so the
real diamonds yeah he told the switchers
just before the switch arutz the
switcheroo he was arrested in
Philadelphia by New York cops and fought
extradition to New York he was let out
on bail and obviously needed more money
so Richard using the name Oxford with
his son whose name is Aidy flower who I
didn't know existed until at this point
in the story yeah they sold nine hundred
thousand dollars worth of stock in a new
corporation they did not keep records of
the stock sales which is what you do
standard wait that's what you do
standard he was arrested again for what
the corporation was created by Professor
Oxford who had learned of a way to make
different colored bricks out of common
garden Durr
what is this is now getting sad this is
[ __ ] sad the spaghetti and it changed
the world
he told investors the brick became so
hard instantly and we're more durable
than normal clay bricks talking about a
brick revolution it's sad it is sad I
mean we're talking about this this used
to be about gold then it was about
diamonds now we got real hard bricks oh
hold on
turns out he had learned of the ancient
process on a trip to Persia that he
never took the plant he was building was
going to be able to crank out four
hundred thousand bricks a day and make
the cuts too many bricks two hundred and
twenty eight thousand a month he said
anyone who invested five thousand would
it get at least a hundred thousand in
return I just he was arrested again for
what the president of the company board
said quote had I known of dr. flowers
history I never would have gone into the
company yeah I did not know that flower
is at present fighting extradition to
New York but the president's suspicion
was raised after professor Oxford gave
him three pearls he said he made he's
just so comfortable lying when the
president had them inspected they
revealed three cheap imitations they
weren't actually pearls so at this point
he's not even going the also his names
are
Oxford's flower he's but he's not even
going like the extra mile now of just
having real pearls saying that he
created him from his ass yeah I don't
know why he did that and it was almost
like being like we're reading this story
it was like the guy like he was like had
this brick thing going and then he all
of a sudden he's like I have pearls like
he just he's fat he'll already he
already had the guy in the guy was he's
out of his [ __ ] mind
the cedilha Sedalia Weekly wrote on
November 29th 1907 quote hundreds of
other companies for the manufacture of
every conceivable object for the
development of every variety of mine
have
promoted by dr. flower as well as
numerous benevolent societies and
Christian Aid organizations the
beneficiary being always dr. Richard C
flower another man's folly yeah right
another man filed charges against dr.
flower quote he asserted that the doctor
pretended to have a secret process for
the manufacture of telegraph poles that
the material was processed into a mold
hardening immediately and that the cost
was nominal and then he had big
contracts from Western railroads he's
got to be stressed he is many lies new
telephone pole company this is a
revolution in telephone polling then we
could change the way telephone pole we
now are able to make a telephone pole
out of [ __ ] what I'm saying is would
is [ __ ] now we have to make something
out of this they grow out of the ground
like beanstalks
which we also have access to beanstalks
yes we have figured out a way and this
is this is a side tip by the way but we
have a way we have some beans but that
we've got and they are not not really
edible beans that are kidney beans
they're not black beans they're not
pinto beans they're not white beans this
is a new beat it's a new bean good lord
and in early testing we found that these
beans when they are in the right soil
which again we only have the technology
to do this soil if thing called the bean
stalk which is essentially what an
enormous vine that will go to the clouds
no no no no now this is all rudimentary
right now and again this is a sidebar
this is not on record but some of the
miners because we're still using miners
for this project written yes these are
these are about nine year old children
they're almost ready to go off in their
own of the world most of our married
with kids of their own sure even
not children imagine their children um
but if you climb this Beanstalk yeah up
there are giants in the clouds I'm sorry
there are giant almost human humans like
us but they're giant in the clouds you
shut up shut up shut your mouth yes and
this is all from a legume this is dates
from a date I wouldn't even call it a
legume
okay these are magic beans these are
their beans but they're not these are
magic beans they're they come from they
actually came out of a room they came
out of a room right and so that's part
of but that's that's not what's
interesting way they came out wait can
we back up a little bit oh I can't
really because when you were in a Giants
have treasure up there okay so you can
get it's called a little groom is where
the beans came from and and yes oh now
you like it again yeah that's great well
this makes sense yes exactly
now ideally we'll be able to go up into
the clouds where the Giants live and
we'll be able to take a bunch of their
giant stuff I mean even if we get a you
know a candlestick from up there that's
that hundred of our candlesticks we'll
throw this stuff down and we'll be able
to you know just sell the materials from
the Giants so that's the latest business
my name is Jack by the way hi
my name's Dave I started ooh BRR
interesting stammering we we we're
basically similar we're similar we're
taking over we're taking over the
characters we're similar types of guys
we basically have a both good business
practice there's nothing money to drive
every carriage driver out of business
and and then make them work for me and
and then they don't have any health
insurance I'll tell you what I don't
think idea like that ever actually being
able to stick around in a society the
beans on the other hand pardon the pun
but the sky's the limit
well the goomy you know what I mean
I'm in great worst business meeting ever
so did I do this right telephone poles
it turns out the tall I read further
into the telephone poles were gonna be
made out of clay oh that's perfect
that's perfect because clay is
indestructible
that's what they say that's prayer I
mean the only downside to that idea is
rain really problem but outside of that
so he does not get bail this time when
he was arrested when Richard was in the
magistrate's office a hypodermic needle
fell out of his pocket no that's
embarrassing
where did that come from someone must be
doing heroin he said he was taking
morphine for quote pains which he
attributed to overwork and protecting
the great Persian process yeah that's
true
the newspaper article went on to quote
dr. Flores claims that he is able to
manufacture diamonds pearls and rubies
as well as bricks Tova bolts well when
you put the list together it's kind of
it's an indictment so there's a there's
a Persian process that he has stumbled
across ancient Persian process that is
able to make diamonds pearls rubies and
bricks and telephone poles yep he used
the standard six he was extradited to
New York given bail and then let me
guess stuck around for trial they jump
bail Oh weird his wife sued mrs.
hagermann his widow Hagah man it turns
out richard and mrs. Hagman took off
together and were spotted in various
locations around the country okay
so ever since Hagman had died he had
been with the wife the wife went to
Philadelphia he was with Maggie means
Widow
okay and so his wife chooses to sue
hagman's Widow yeah
in September 1908 police in Richmond
Virginia detained mrs. hagermann and
seized quote trunks full of finery and
gems
Larry look at this there's a shitload of
gems in here in the finery they
they were made in a room they also
arrested a man believed to be dr. flour
okay
Wow so he's at that point but the police
arrested him they breasted him under the
quote blanket charge of being suspicious
characters okay so the Giuliani laws
it's not a great arrest right a judge
how is there not enough to get him on
now Your Honor these are suspicious
characters he's not the guy who's ripped
off millions of dollars lazy fairies so
they couldn't so wherever he would get
arrested they needed time to then sent
documentation to prove it was him okay
and in that time he would often get out
of jail by a judge like his charges are
nonsense so he was often ahead of the
[ __ ] thing it sounds not stressful
though yeah so a judge releases them two
days later though virginia police
believed he was wanted in many other
cities for grand larceny and really
wanted in new york they had to let dr.
flowers go Virginia police blame the
apathy of the New York police for his
release because the New York cops when
the Virginia cops were like Santa's town
documents are a cop or whatever the New
York cops decided not to send someone to
get Richard because they didn't believe
it was him okay good good good good good
at this point Richard's wife had had it
she filed for divorce on grounds that he
was running around the country with
another woman yeah
she was granted a divorce in 1910
Richard continued to travel and swindle
he traveled all over the West's into
Mexico he was finally caught in Toronto
in 1914 he actually went to Europe for a
little bit used cotton Toronto in 1914
after eleven years on the run Wow
he had lived in Toronto for two years
the Pinkertons found him Wow
the New York Times said he was quote
broken by age and drugs he was sentenced
to a year in jail on December 8th 1914
and after getting out he moved to New
Jersey as an old broken-down man Richard
died suddenly in a theater in Hoboken
New Jersey September 9
1860 Wow yeah what was he like was that
the biggest bullshitter up but up until
then was this the most he was really one
of the King all-time bullshitters yeah I
mean they were a lot of guys that did a
lot of [ __ ] but he he was like I think
that the level of just horseshit that
came out of this [ __ ] guy was just
astounding that people bought it and
everywhere he went he would just rely I
was I mean telephone poles and diamonds
like it's [ __ ] clothes I like it's
almost like he's trying to see how
stupid people are and realizing they're
really stupid you're more dumb than you
can ever imagine
Wow but you know the more we did the one
we did like have you read about fairness
or I was gonna do a podcast on it but
there's so many other things that are
out about it now luckily I documentary
there's the HBO you should watch I mean
oh I know what you're talking about
right all right so it was this blood
making machine it was never real could
could literally defy the laws of physics
it was just completely impossible to
create and and and it's like this she
and her cohort just keep saying it's
real and every expert in the field is
like this can't be real and it just it's
like Enron like the people who know are
like this is not a thing that can be
happening yeah but everyone's like I'm
in and like with the ther knows thing
like all the Kissinger and all these
[ __ ] George Shultz are there on the
board of the company like it's just this
[ __ ] thing and everyone wants to
believe it because they want to [ __ ]
make money I mean it that's the in it
that's the bottom line is every wants to
[ __ ] make a bunch of money yeah so no
one's like oh we should actually look
into this yeah it's just all garbage and
the reals like FTA yeah the smart guys
don't invest in it no like oh this is
[ __ ] stupid and then all these idiots
with money just throw their [ __ ]
money on it we live in the juicer Oh
economy like literally this is what so
much of Silicon Valley is they're all
[ __ ] and Richard flowers the whole
[ __ ] town is just a pack of [ __ ]
lies
a lie and well and it also is like it
rewards the big dream with no reality
attached to it totally so it's just like
yeah anybody can say that I've got the
thing that's going to do this
life-changing thing yeah
just cuz you open a office with a living
wall a living wall yeah that's one of
those fancy Silicon Valley places oh
they are yeah yeah it's it's kind of
crazy to think that this happened in the
1800s and absolutely nothing has changed
well and that it doesn't it just it it
doesn't I mean it's it's crazy because
it's early it's not crazy because it's
foreign right it's crazy because like
but this is it is what it is what we
live in now I mean I mean really when
you think about even the presidency now
it is being the CEO of a big [ __ ]
company yeah it's all [ __ ] [ __ ]
and you're selling you are your your job
is to come up with the right rhetoric to
sell the [ __ ] again to the people so
it's how do you reinvent the [ __ ]
and sell it again who can sell it the
best but it's not about changing or
fixing or finding or no it's you know or
helping there's one of things like well
if we're not in the middle of capitalism
is any of this [ __ ] happening yeah
because it's really just God I mean the
jute the juicer juice arrow or that one
is [ __ ] room that one's amazing but
that that that shows that shows the like
the actual level of how empty something
can really be and yeah it emits fire
fast it's all these things that are just
like beneath them there's nothing but
the outsides shiny and that is a lot of
times it the way it's rewarded now it's
um it's at least it's enough to make you
temporarily wealthy and and it's and
it's enough to like get you money to
like be considered legitimate and even
you know there's also this like a a lot
of it's very American and British but
there was this story I read about
why we can't have high speed trains and
the reason we can have high speed trains
in America isn't because of the
technology or no right it's it's the
graft it it costs so much more money to
build a train in England or America than
it does in it's like five times the
amount than any other country on earth
in Japan it's much cheaper in black
graft what does that mean it just
corruption Oh rush so much [ __ ]
corruption yeah every level that
everyone's just [ __ ] siphoning off
the system and that's all these guys are
doing they're essentially just siphoning
off they create a [ __ ] comedy and
they siphon a bunch of [ __ ] money off
like uber going public like that that is
that is yeah that is Richard flap
there's no money to be made yeah they
haven't done anything it is just
[ __ ] and not refute it you go
they're losing a billion dollars every
year it's keeping the lights on until
like for everyone else out everyone's
gonna give them money and at some point
it's all gonna collapse cuz there's
nothing there yeah the only thing
they've ever done that I think is
interesting is you have a jam pad no
scooters oh yeah right the scooters are
actually a cool thing that is actually a
good thing for the environment and and
it helps honestly it's one of those
things like it helps poor people move
around maybe better than most other ways
yeah it's a good technology but they
didn't invent it someone else came up
with scooters lime or whatever and then
they jumped in and bought your scooters
right like uber has no future
uber is George flour who's just made a
fake mine yeah it's gonna eventually be
exposed and collapse but there's just so
much of it yeah so model the Train thing
is so annoying because it is like you
know I mean it's it's all so different
now because of climate change
yeah that it's like at the point where
you are just like what is the [ __ ]
endgame to just need to die on top of
the most money it's crazy like that
that's literally it
and then and then everything is dead
around you and everything and you're
dead and everything's gone
great that's that's that's our that's
our gym you know mining companies are
one of the reasons I brought up my that
I hate mining so much is because so the
way mining companies operate is they
will go in and they will dig up and just
absolutely environmentally destroy an
area and they'll have a parent company
and they will keep giving money to the
parent company and then when they've
mined everything they can out of the
mine and obliterated the area turn into
this [ __ ] hazard toxic nightmare then
they go oh we don't have any money left
and then they leave and then there's
this giant [ __ ] nightmare that has to
be taken care of by the government and
everybody has to pay for it
it's a [ __ ] graft yeah like you if
you want to start a mine you should be
like oh and then here's the amount of
money you have to pay at the end because
you're gonna dig up the earth and put a
bunch of toxic [ __ ] out there yeah and
now the mines not actually profitable is
it no because it's a [ __ ] graft
it's a [ __ ] way and and yeah and it's
everything oh good that ended on a nice
depressing note fricking well now we
have a president that's just straight up
the most obvious grifter of all [ __ ]
time yeah beautiful because it takes the
transparency off the office which has
always been a oh it's not a gift really
tell that to Obama's one hundred million
dollars and the Clintons hundred million
dollars it's a [ __ ] grift
it's you become president to make a
hundred million dollars that's why you
do it yeah and that's what are you doing
130 years yeah yeah you make [ __ ] they
didn't make it illegal to get insider
trader information in Congress until
2007 that's until 2007
you could go to Congress and tell them
what you were gonna do with your
technology and then they could buy stock
in it and get [ __ ] rich and they
didn't stop that until 2007 the whole
[ __ ] thing is just [ __ ] [ __ ] I
will say it's nice to see the Chuck
Schumer's
well I like to see that I like to know
that that guy's got some I like to know
oh my god I hope a car falls on them
yeah no no it is and what it does is it
gives you the system we have now where
you have millionaires arguing about the
best way to bail the rest of us out yeah
the low stakes theatrical faux battle
that the millionaires on the news
stations
yeah that's tell you about anyway we'll
sign cars and we do sonic cars yeah
did we oh yeah we're gonna have some
announcements on dates coming up in a
couple of weeks in May we got some dates
that we're gonna drop and tickets will
be available so big announcements in
there yeah yeah we're gonna Dave and I
are getting conjoined and what country
should we move to when this all falls
apart well we better hurry because I had
a mom just cause of Van Halen
we should go to Persia yep that's where
all the that's where you get the Rubicon
technology they have so many telephone
poles there yeah thank God it doesn't
rain okay Merry Christmas